welcome to this video playing gusta for
named Gustavo foul 95 from mmm South
America Venezuela Colombia Venezuela
okay so I wasn't totally off Wow 83 I
usually play with Quincy 7 I just
accidentally played Knight f6 but ok it
still should be quite quite okay for
black g6 um makes a somewhat strange
impression at first because it looks at
this well protected d4 pawn but what I'm
just playing is the idea of the setup to
get with Bishop f5 get the light squared
Bishop sixth and build up this
configuration with the night only form
which is quite interesting leading to an
active play I can even try to he really
wants to exchange it um ok take on d
tool hm I don't really mind mind him
taking it
and maybe can take with the denied and
play Queen age five
hmm this might be an idea okay prior
probably need to get rid of this and
hmm not quite sure what setup oh I
should don't play here this is slight
problem here those pieces it's not like
white as is having an attack or anything
but I'm not so sure what to do I'd I
originally wanted to go with rook g8 do
something on the G far but I don't see
this at the moment really I can rotate I
have no place for this Bishop to go was
always Bishop f6 okay I went for
something entirely different trying to
do something on the queenside hoping
that my good structure with pawns on
light squares will pay off just use this
square
yeah you can play 95 now but I think
this should be quite ok now intending
really f 6m
should i still play f6f six takes things
yeah it shouldn't be bad really I mean
he has played b3 and we can just go
inside enormously so if we trade Queens
this should be quite ok I have play
against the sea pawn my e-cig spawn
technically also looks like a week porn
but there's no way to put pressure on it
that's always have night to you for so
what is he thinking about really he must
exchange anyway I think at least check
now kamini eight looks like totally
forced yes yes this idea to to put it on
see fire but I think 94 is coming first
now look here ok
yeah how does he protects e3a some
tactical way to do it like rookie one
maybe you're okay one try to look at the
six spawn of King f7 though can take
next okay if I take it and threatening
92 which is very important of course
okay 95 in dr now of course
hmm why do I actually go now with the
night it's not not easy at all
we a five and be for who night see 50 k
95 I can sec the exchange this is pretty
okay because i have have this pond the
spawn math in the center my idea was
roxy to be four and you cannot take
twice because of 90 to check winning
material night before 92 wins material
so i have established this night on c3
year it's not bad now we might take it
on before okay don't see
okay maybe can play okay one now but i
have not be five that's a good reply get
deformed okay the other thing is I don't
really have okay well this is also
possible going into this end game k 5
y'all I'm a pawn up this this is a quite
nice Center okay put it here and then
you folks at the right moment fattening
now to take on f3 okay not f3
immediately add but now right f3b time
morning b-17g 7 that's okay
yeah i was also threatening this year
it's quite nice just promoting yeah it
was lost it was a loss rook endgame I
think check don't really see how he
could have defended the check
white forfeits on time yeah I think I
think this is this this is lost really
because I have this big bone mass of the
center angie's doesn't really have any
counter play that some should be quite
nice I think probably around here is the
critical position of all this this is
what he played 95 was interesting of
course my dear the computer let's start
with the comp he wants it wants to do
this and get a check on him with the
equal play funny enough my idea maybe
was bad i don't know my idea was to do
this and then play b form just claiming
that i have enough compensation here
with those pawns at bone will start to
roll computer place this smooth
interesting trying to take here rook c8
takes takes andrew k5 f4 0.44 white
which is pretty much telling you that it
does not know how to assess the position
or its it's simply not clear in a
practical game its profits it so it's
okay for black anyway but because you
always have chances here with the pawns
but how to tell objectively very hard to
tell
I had 92 this was this I should have
seen really it's much better or i'm not
sure but it was it was something that i
should consider simply because it's it's
rather apparent this idea it's not so
it's not one hundred percent clear with
this counter play computers 10000
interesting yeah this was a complicated
complicated endgame that we got when i'm
pretty sure about is that this snow
should be good for black may be here
here 95 okay though this is the this is
the exchange think of sorry this is what
you did before thick steaks yeah i'm
just to show you cannot check take
because of that trick yeah but here it's
it's it's I don't really see how we can
maybe okay maybe he can play night
before only after some prep moves like
this for example gaining a bit of space
on the King side and exchanging pawns
does this might be an idea really so
play it like that and only later get
this idea into into the action okay
maybe maybe okay thanks for watching